immigration negotiations sidetracked by
a storm of a comments by President Trump
yesterday that he now claims weren't
accurately reported the president says
the language used by me at the daka
meeting was tough but this was not the
language used what was really tough was
the outlandish proposal made a big
setback for daca never said anything
derogatory about Haitians other than
Haiti is obviously a very poor in
trouble country never said take them out
made up by Dems I have a wonderful
relationship of Haitians probably should
record future meetings unfortunately no
trust mr. Trump didn't respond to
questions today about the incident after
a ceremony at the White House here's how
some of the president's frequent critics
reacted to the reports the President of
the United States is racist we now know
that we have in the White House someone
who could lead the Ku Klux Klan in the
United States of America somebody who
could be the leader of the neo-nazi and
publish just his words this is someone
who's chosen a path that is absolutely
racism with steroids
perhaps the White House feels the
president's remarks will be
well-received in some parts of this
country among some parts of the
president's base and perhaps that is
true but it doesn't make what he said
any less ignorant or any less racist our
president is a clear and present danger
to non-white people in America it's that
simple all right so obviously some
widespread criticism and of course
people on the Left Jesse that have
disfavor with the president find that he
is racist then bring his base in to say
that the base is also racist and that he
shouldn't be in the White House not fit
to govern yeah I mean the left is seized
on this but Trump gave him the weapon he
shouldn't have said it it wasn't a
classy thing to say it was crude it was
rude I wouldn't say it but Trump's
offensive and we've known Trump says
offensive things for a very long time so
it shouldn't come as any surprise
he's also issued a denial of it and it's
very yet no one knows exactly what was
said except him and the people in the
room but putting that aside the point he
was making is that these countries that
he was talking about
I don't believe our s whole countries
they're impoverished they're riddled
with corruption and they have a lot of
problems with that said he was saying he
believes in merit-based immigration that
was I think what he was trying to get at
because people in the room were saying
let's do a deal where we bring in these
people from third world countries and
the president has made it very clear he
wants to bring in people that are based
on merit whether they it's a high
education whether it's English speaking
those are the things that he wants to
focus on and in immigration policy he's
trying to put forth that's the priority
for him what got lost in his gaffe I
would say was that people now aren't
talking about that and the deal is
really hanging in the balance and he had
a lot of momentum going into this the
tax thing was doing great he had it's
great meeting and he was going to bring
together a lot of people on an
immigration overhaul and now all that's
been lost so he needs it too a lot to
regain the momentum I dislike the people
on the Left who and I know people and
you know people that have you know been
at cocktail parties they call the Bronx
an [ __ ] they called middle america a
nestle these people that are in their
studios and they're put yet they're
putting people down that live in
different parts of the country they call
the south hicks they called christians
bad things people that say bad things
you know what did Obama say about bitter
cleaners Hillary called half the country
deplorable people so the the reaction in
the media when they say Trump says this
about another country there have been
Democrats that said horrible things
about people in our own country and have
not gotten criticized nearly as much as
the president so there's a little
hypocrisy there but again with that said
obviously the president said the wrong
thing here and has to do a lot better
moving forward when it comes to blunt
talk okay all right so Dana how do you
see this in terms of you know that the
communications being handled by the
White House in response to this well you
know if they wanted to deny it last
night would have been the night to deny
it apparently there were reports that
there were calls being made is to check
in with people that they'd like to talk
to and everybody was giving him the
thumbs up and then this morning
that changed and he said that's actually
not what I said so we're actually doing
two things now we're having people who
are defending the comments but even if
he didn't say the comments the comments
are okay meaning that's some of the
defenders are saying that so agreeing
with what Jesse said in that it's not
exactly surprising that you would have
profanity in the White House this has
happened in every White House remember
in 2000 when I think was President Bush
at the time a candidate said that one of
the New York Times reporters was a major
league a really Dan please time okay
then you have Joe Biden in the White
House saying when he's about to sign
Obamacare you know mr. president this is
a big effing deal like profanity is not
the issue the sentiment is but I would
say that aside from all of that and I
don't need to go into how I feel about
it the question is what do you want to
accomplish and what you need to do and
who do you need to help you do it and
senator dick durbin is one of those
people and what happened is this makes
it so much harder for dick Durbin to
convince his Democrats to go along with
him to try to get these deals done and
this is not just about the daka deal
about the spending and the chip money
that children's health insurance program
because now there are Democrats on that
side that are gonna dig in and they're
gonna say I'm not going to want to be a
part of this you have to push back
harder on President Trump when but the
sad thing is on Tuesday they had a
really good meeting and by Friday now I
think they're farther apart than they
were earlier in the week and they've got
seven days until the next government
shutdown okay so Greg it wasn't
fortuitous timing to say Polly so as
Dana points out it's with Durbin and
others in a bit of a position the
president is denying that he said this
but the timing of it perhaps should have
come quickly on the heels yesterday and
where does it go from here and what do
you make of it
well Durbin is a bozo let's be frank on
this one I mean this is a guy who said
chain migration is a racist term because
of the word chain so let's not forget
that the big issue the thing that really
bugs me it's not fair that all the other
networks get to say the word and when we
can't
that's your take no that desert it's
like when you know you're a kid
and one of your friends parents lets him
go see r-rated movies yeah but your
parents won't
that's FoxNews they won't let us say the
word actually they haven't told this
this is the parent if they're saying
they're you know what I mean yeah it's
like it's like yeah you shouldn't be
saying that I asked if we could say the
word and they said we couldn't
so that's they shot they yeah they there
is also a sense here like I I don't
appreciate the language either and in
fact actually when I when you hear you
got you know I hope he means the
countries and not the people you think
that's what I'm hoping but that has to
be asked if he means the people he needs
to clarify did he mean the countries or
the I'm hoping he meant the country and
I and he can prove that by just saying
merit-based immigration can take people
from those s whole countries I could
think that those cut like you have to
separate these two issues I can believe
that these countries are really bad but
people that come they're real it can be
really good that's all he has to do I
think now that like I say I find the
word terrible and all that stuff
but I'm not gonna be self-righteous
about it because when I watch the other
meet when I watch the media do it I just
wanna I just can't handle how self
righteous and sanctimonious they are I
mean these are people that if they went
to a gym and there wasn't the right
smoothie bar in there they would call
that an [ __ ] especially if they were
living in New York City if not the gym
didn't have a personalized TV in front
of their stair climber
that's an [ __ ] I mean I everybody
uses that word now you're right about
the sentiment that's why I think that
you have to divide it but the point is
and then I'll shut up it's always gonna
be about rhetoric versus action and
right now nothing Donald Trump has done
in terms of action has been the problem
in fact the country is doing really well
we've got high optimism in small
business we've got a crazy stock market
people are getting bonuses you're seeing
Iran maybe there might be a secular
revolution you're seeing North Korea
things happening but the issue among the
we've media is always going to be this
course rhetoric which we all
I think admit it quite pot is always
been the problem so Donald Trump makes
Donald Trump a heavy lift for everybody
because it's like it's like a four-hour
drive to Disneyland right when it's
closing you only get an hour of rides
and that's what Trump is he's a
four-hour ride to Disneyland when it's
about to close as long as the economy
does well and his actions are good
people will accept this heavy lift but
if the economy goes down and there's a
board there's an ugly war or something
something bad happens then it's gonna be
an issue but I think people people
already know what they got I know but
right know what they get people getting
caught up on the semantics little
semantics to mask you saying I'm you
know disapprove of the language it's
colorful etc as Dana said it's nothing
new that we've seen in White House
administration Congress whatever every
place workplace however Greg brings up
one good point finally thank God which
you look at the list you know of
accomplishments so we're super focused
here on the language but what about the
accomplishments shouldn't the Democrats
be fair and focus on that as well I
think anybody can be fair but this is
not about being feared the man told a
lie this morning the compounded his
racial comments yesterday his own White
House didn't deny it and now he comes
out at the last moment after I guess
he's watching Fox and Friends and sees
that even people who are stalwart
supporters are saying hey this was
really unforgivably shouldn't have done
this it's wrong and then he says all I
didn't quite say it that way and I you
know that language wasn't quite the same
I'm amazed at how many Republicans are
put into the difficult position of
having to defend President Trump over
and over again I mean and distracting
from the agenda but maybe it's an
intentional distraction maybe it's
abstract I don't know but in this case
he has offended people so deeply and yet
Republicans are in like Paul Ryan today
well you know it was wrong that
shouldn't have done but he won't say you
know what this is across the line you
can't say this about fellow people in
this world with certainly Americans well
how many Haitian Americans African
Americans are Salvadoran Americans are
making a great contribution to this
country people who are hard-working
the greg's point
this is not about the country's great it
is about the people yes verify that
hasn't clarified that allow me to speak
the reason that I say it's about the
people is because it was in the course
of a discussion about the lottery and
you know he wants the lottery done away
with he says why do we need a lottery to
get in here
you shouldn't it should be he wants to
cut legal immigration half but the
lottery system he objects to on the
basis that it should be about merit it
shouldn't be about a lottery right the
library was created however because
there is a shortage of people coming
from certain countries in the normal
flow so the idea was we're going to try
to engineer it so as to repair that and
create opportunities for people from all
over the world as America comes back and
says oh no we don't want people from
those countries
that's about people great and they'd say
that to imagine what you would say the
Irish coming from famine the Jews came
from Germany if he says parently for
Norwegian he says that a meritocracy
American meritocracy based immigration
allows people from those countries and
it's fine but if he says it does it then
you're right but we don't know that well
I would be contrary to what we say on
the Statue of Liberty it doesn't say
well take your brightest and richest it
says we'll take people so you're against
the whole meritocracy no no no you know
let's have a discussion what's right
what I'm saying is what he said
yesterday was so deeply offensive and
wrong and I can't believe that
Republicans and even Trump people should
be up in arms he somehow suggested oh
his people would agree to this they're
not all racist I think they understand
that he is you're rude rich uncle well
he's using colorful language but
nevertheless when you look at the merits
of what he's talking about it should be
a merit-based system there's serious
significant problems with chain
migration so language aside those issues
have to be dealt with in a responsible
way